[Music]
the buzz on orange is the new black I'd
become addicted to it my wife's addicted
there are so many people who of course
who were talking about the show and
what's cool is you get really you got
some neat guest directors yeah we've had
some pretty incredible people come
through Jodie Foster probably a you know
first first person to come to mind she
directed an episode he directed an
episode she drew it
she directed an episode for me I had
some interesting stuff to do I had to my
character was researching this thing
called edging which is where you
essentially you masturbate but you you
don't come to completion and you you
basically it involves the street it
involves a strategically placed digit
and then you like don't anyway my point
is what's the point I mean I saw that
episode but I remember what the point is
I'm trying to do that to your side donut
actually gets the fun part I Conan
listen you're you're speaking my song I
have no idea what what is a real bad
song yeah
honestly I honestly have no idea I
imagine it has something to do with you
know building it up you know so that
it's really I'm sorry let's just say I'm
glad my legs are crossed right now yeah
I know so so anyway this all had to be
done in front of in front of Jody and
you had to simulate the eye and this was
tell she was kind of uh you know it was
a little awkward for her I mean she's
amazing if she's directed so many things
and she's obviously a world-class
actress and the whole thing and she was
I could tell she was a little nervous
like coming in and and giving me
direction and she was like I don't know
Jason should you be doing it more less
faster harder and she was really it was
awkward and I was like foster don't
worry I got this
Foster Foster what a creep I'm a foster
I got this I made a career of this babe
you go you go back to winning Oscars
I'll handle this yeah they called
American pop yeah I got you did
I just have to ask you quickly the
American Pie movies they're out there
they're running constantly do you get
recognized around the world for it
you must yeah they're probably not a
country you can go to where they don't
know you it's uh it's bring a pie to
your table yeah yeah well I tell you
there's there's they're having some
pretty random encounters and places and
situations
I was recently in Turkey and is actually
crazy we were we came into the country
via boat but we I guess a we who you
with oh I was with sorry I was with my
wife and then my sister-in-law and
brother-in-law and we came in via bow
but we for whatever reason didn't get
our passports stamped properly right to
come into the country and then we flew
out of the country so my in-laws left
first so they're leaving the airport and
they are getting their passports checked
and there's no stamps they are taken to
like a holding cell in Istanbul Airport
where they are detained they're getting
in all sorts of trouble like it's all
Shady meanwhile it's scary it's pretty
freaky they're calling me and my wife
now because we're supposed to leave the
next day and they're like you need to
handle this you don't have a stamp in
your passport and because we were
supposed to fly you know the next day
and they're like you better get on this
so I'm freaking out we go down to the
harbor where we came in and now we're
like you know trying to talk to the
harbor master and try to I've never
wanted to be recognized so much in my
life I was literally like we're trying
to talk to these guys and they're so
scary looking and there's like you don't
have stamp on your passport you this is
illegal this is all this stuff and
clearly they wanted some money but you
know I didn't want to give them money
and
and but I was like literally like hat
off sunglasses off I mean I I was like
looking for a pie to in front of them
[Applause]
I'm in this business a long time I've
never seen a better place to go to
commercial them right now